[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle aurélien nabila je
suis designer indépendant artiste et
enseignant dans ma pratique de
transmission je remarque que la
créativité de mes étudiants est
extrêmement par leur volonté de
bien faire
c'est bien de vouloir bien faire alors
pourquoi est-ce un obstacle à la
créativité
mes étudiantes et les étudiants ont
souvent en tête une idée précise
parfaite de la forme finale qu'ils
pensent être attendu d'eux dans cette
perspective il essaye tout de suite de
bricoler quelque chose qui ressemble le
résultat d'une telle méthode est
malheureusement à la fois attendue est
bancal dans cette perspective orientée
par le but
si l'on veut faire apparaître une fleur
on va mettre en place un carcan sur
mesure un échafaudage qui va précisément
à la hauteur voulue et puis on
n'essaiera le remplir avec ce qui
ressemble le plus à une fleur par
opposition
j'aimerais vous proposer de préparer la
terre de la nourrir d'y planter une
graine de la rose est de prendre soin de
la plante d'adapter votre soin à chaque
étape de son développement pour ensuite
profiter d'être le témoin comblé de la
floraison créative pour que la
créativité et lieu sa forme finale ne
peut pas et ne doit pas être être
attendu davance la créativité consiste
plutôt à l'installation d'un terreau
fertile d'où les idées jailliront
ensuite naturellement
alors comment est ce que l'on installe
un terreau fertile
moi j'adore cette phrase de nietzsche il
faut porter du chaos en soi pour
accoucher d'une étoile dansante
mais pour vous c'est quoi ce chaos tout
projet créatif commence par des
recherches on s'entoure de l'univers
contextuel du projet on rassemble des
projets du même type
cela permet d'adopter une posture de
réceptivité
on ne se place pas en démiurge qui
attendent à coucher mais on s'ouvre et
on se rend réceptifs aux qualités qui
émerge de ce que l'on découvre
cela permet de découvrir la qualité
vivante de la créativité
quand on commence en processus
d'idéation on va commencer par un
brainstorming on étale d'abord
généreusement et intuitivement notre
inspiration un brainstorming doit être
libre de toute forme d'autocensure on
met tout sur la table sans jugement
alors attention là c'est très important
à cette étape on doit être persuadé que
l'autocensure va venir
on ne nie surtout pas son existence en
croyant que l'on va foncer tête baissée
dans le grand bain créatif au contraire
on attend d'eux mêmes l'autocensure de
pied ferme et on coupe ses racines dès
qu'elle pointe le bout de son nez en
écrivant noir sur blanc cette idée
bizarre que notre auto censeurs voulait
nous faire avaler là on commence à être
vraiment familier avec la qualité
vivante de la créativité on voit le jeu
en oeuvre quand les idées se manifestent
d'elle-même et que l' on essaye
activement de les étouffer
voir ce jeu et sa qualité absurde rend
l'exercice créatif assez drôle c'est bon
signe
et ça ouvre un vrai espace un espace
joyeux dans la masse des idées que l'on
a laissé sortir on va ensuite distinguer
des idées qui nous appellent d'elle-même
qui frétille d'impatience sur leurs
papiers
on va alors accorder du temps et de
l'attention à ses idées on va regarder
ce qu'elles ont dans le ventre
pas du tout avec la pensée mais en
continuant griffonné à mac était ainsi
on devient vraiment familier avec la
qualité gerbante du travail un parfait
quand on va travailler par itérations on
va devoir interroger très rapidement
beaucoup d'idées donc il serait bon
d'être encore plus familier avec cette
autocensure et ceux qui la provoque
pourquoi est ce que l'on empêche nos
idées novatrices de sortir la
méthodologie obsédé par le résultat
posent deux problèmes
tout d'abord donc on a vu ça au boutis
vraiment un résultat classique et
fragile ensuite et c'est encore plus
grave et plus répandue c'est le blocage
créatif au début de mes études en design
j'avais tellement peur que l'on voit mon
travail en cours un parfait que je
faisais tout pour que l'on ne voit pas
mon écran comme il était évidemment
difficile à cacher en public je ne
faisais rien je ne travaillais pas
c'était la meilleure façon pour que
personne ne voit mon travail un parfait
pourtant bien vivant et en pleine
gestation
crispés sur la résine sur la réalisation
d'un résultat parfait je ne faisais rien
en début de projet parce que je savais
que cela serait faible chaotique en
chantier et ce n'est pas du tout en
adéquation avec l'image que je me
faisais du résultat final
alors je m'autocensure et et rien ne
sortait vouloir bien faire empêche
littéralement de faire alors quand
pourquoi est-ce qu'on empêche nos idées
créatives de sortir nous sommes très
marqué par la peur que les idées que
l'on offre à voir nous définissent dans
cette perspective montré une idée en
chantier qui expose ses failles nous
expose nous aussi dans toute notre
imperfection
c'est ça qui me terrorisait que l'on se
rende compte que j'étais un être humain
on a souvent peur que la créativité nous
amène et parfois en public sur un
terrain que l'on ne peut pas contrôler
bon on a bien raison c'est exactement ce
qu'elle fait mais c'est pas grave c'est
une bonne nouvelle si la peur est là
c'est que le terrain est nouveau et que
la créativité est encore à l'oeuvre
cependant ne pas laisser nos idées
créatives nous définir permet de nous
ouvrir vraiment un tout autre rapport
avec elle revenons à notre brainstorming
décomplexée et libre d'autocensure ce
qui en résulte est une richesse non
familière c'est un gage d'originalité
une idée créative
parce que je ne la connaissais pas d'
avance ce rapport de nom familiarité un
magnifique avantage on aurait presque
pas l'idée d'en réclamer la paternité ou
la maternité
cependant
accorder son indépendance à la création
permet vraiment d'avoir un tout autre
rapport avec l on a reconnu qu'on n'a
pas besoin de se crisper
vraiment on développe un rapport sain et
direct difficultés qui apparaissent on
est ouvert et on voit les idées qui
émergent d'elle-même ceux d identifier
de ses idées créatives permet d'adopter
une confiance qui n'est plus une
confiance en soi
le doute qui reste est souvent est ce
que les idées avec lesquelles je
travaille que j'ai laissé sortir sont
vraiment des graines qui vont pouvoir
germées mais dans le processus créatif
la confiance provient de la certitude
sereine qu'absolument en tout est une
graine
tout est une graine pourvu qu'on la rose
d'attention et d'énergie pour ainsi dire
de travail c'est ce que l'on découvre en
ce qu'aime en se familiarisant avec la
qualité vivante de la créativité
on n'est plus en train de se crisper sur
ce qu'on en a déjà mais on s'ouvre et la
confiance se manifestent réellement
d'elle-même mais alors la peur on s'en
est toujours pas vraiment débarrasser
ben non
la créativité c'est le courage de faire
advenir l'inattendu de jouer avec le
chaos pour faire advenir la nouveauté
quand je suis créatif je ne débarrasse
pas de la peur j'accepte qu'elle soit là
et je rentre en amitié avec elle
j'arrête d'avoir peur de la peur j'ai
une relation vivante et ouverte avec m
pour moi ça a tout changé
en plus de pouvoir laisser voir mon
écran et mes recherches je peux parler
de mes inquiétudes et en plus de
recevoir du soutien je reçois de
nouvelles idées vous voyez c'est tout
bénef courage se disait que rage
il s'agit bien de rencontrer son coeur
et ce qu'il a à nous dire et non de le
mettre de côté ou de le mater le coeur
donne de la force de l'allant l'envi de
jouer avec l'inconnu d'y plonger
joyeusement on en a tellement besoin
on ne peut littéralement pas s'en passer
bon alors ça sent pas un peu le bazar
tout ça quand même
on ne va rien contrôler et on va laisser
être le chaos si l'on ne va pas
contrôler on va développer de la
maîtrise
olala on va beaucoup plus s'amuser et ce
sera beaucoup moins crispant oui on va
laisser être mais pour en assurer le bon
développement
on va s'accorder à se plier alors
comment on va s'assurer s'accorder
vraiment à la nouveauté dans le chaos
on y va on est exactement à l'intuition
de l'intuition
nous avons souvent une idée mécanique et
passive qui équivaudrait à posséder une
sorte de radar qui nous dirait où aller
comme si j'avais la parfaite baguette de
sourcier le parfait pendule magique que
je pourrai suivre enfin les yeux fermés
parce que l'on est d'accord dans un
monde complexe et changeant c'est
complètement vertigineux de se demander
qui a t'il autour de moi qui me parle
qu'est-ce qu'ils m'appellent j'aimerais
être sûr et certain de ce qui est bon
pour moi
en général on voit que tous nous appelle
en même temps ou que tous nous repousse
dans un même mouvement de peur de peur
du mauvais choix de s'enfermer dans une
voie qui ne serait pas la nôtre pas
parfaite
alors on veut être certain cet espoir
d'être enfin certains est absolument et
luzoir est profondément violent en effet
qu'est ce qu'une vie ou plus rien d'un
projet ne peut plus arriver ça ressemble
quand même beaucoup à la mort vous ne
trouvez pas heureusement de la véritable
confiance en la vie n'est un rapport
beaucoup plus à son intuition mes
étudiants pensent que la question de
leur intuition de ce qui les appelle et
restreint au chant du design que je veux
savoir quelle est leur designer favoris
ou leur typographie ou leur interface
préféré mais maintenant qu'ils sont dans
le bain l'intérêt de mes étudiants pour
le design en tant que discipline fermé
n'est plus du tout importante ce qui
t'intéresse en ce moment c'est la
stratégie du football l'archéologie les
plantes médicinales
ok très bien alors vas-y fonce dedans va
y chercher de l'énergie
je dis à mes étudiants choisissez un axe
qui correspond
ce que vous aimez en ce moment ne vous
justifiez pas aux frais mois ce qui vous
anime le plus étalez le sur la table
coupez le en morceaux faisant votre
matières premières votre carburant
en général c'est très personnel ça leur
revient de leur histoire familiale de
leur culture de la spiritualité de leurs
ancêtres du métier de leurs voisins
cette intuition du moment ça doit être
il doit être tellement précis c'est un
vecteur ça doit être précis solide et
précis comme un diamant
cette intuition du moment ne vous défini
en rien elle ne vous engage en rien vous
pouvez en changer demain radicalement si
vous le souhaitez mais demain vous
choisirez un nouvel axe précis un
vecteur si serré que vous pourrez de
nouveau et déployer toute votre énergie
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que dans
chaque projet il ya un vrai moyen
personnel de se relier à la situation de
se faire vraiment plaisir et ça vous le
savez que c'est lorsque l'on se fait
plaisir que l'on est créatif
d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant si ce
qui est créatif et non familier pourquoi
est-ce que l'intuition de l'impression
de toucher quelque chose de proche qui
nous fait du bien comme si on avait
touché quelque chose que l'on cherche et
parce que l'ouverture nous rafraîchit
naturellement en offrant de l'espace à
l'action et à la pensée le processus
intuitif touche l'ouver ce que l'on ne
contrôle pas il offre le délice de la
non crispation delà des saisies dans
l'ouvert on se retrouve soi même ce soit
indéfinie et libre qui peut tout un
carnet on se retrouve alors joyeux
joueurs et courageux parce que l'on est
libre
l'intuition est donc à la fois une
rencontre de l'un team est une
invitation au grand saut dans l'inconnu
alors pour être puissamment et
sereinement créatif on va donc utiliser
la confiance en notre intuition pour
établir un champ d'action précis et la
force du coeur pour y déployer de
l'énergie mais comment garder la force
nécessaire pour continuer à travailler
si la direction change au fur et à
mesure des 10
sculpté et des obstacles on a peur de
que ce soit tout temps fatiguant de
devoir tout le temps s'adapter de se
retrouver à nouveau débutants alors que
l'on vient peine de maîtriser quelque
chose on a souvent peur de s'épuiser en
s'adaptant parce que l'on associe
l'adaptation une posture passive qui
obéirait à des injonctions extérieures
heureusement la souplesse n'est pas se
transformer douloureusement en
permanence mais se reconnaître ouvert et
pouvoir ainsi s'étendre dans toutes les
directions et toutes les situations
la souplesse est une posture de
réceptivité qui a dépassé un antagonisme
actif-passif crispé territoriale à la
place d'un territoire à défendre
j'aimerais vous offrir de reconnaître
votre zone de confort
elle n'est pas à la mode on vous demande
en permanence d'en sortir et l'image
d'une faiblesse d'une lâcheté qui ne va
pas affronter le monde alors
premièrement laisser le monde tranquille
ensuite quelle violence que de demander
à quelqu'un de sortir de sa zone de
confort
c'est grâce à leur reconnaissance de cet
espace familier que l'on peut engager un
mouvement courageux vers le nom familier
j'ai appris quelque chose
lorsque j'ai demandé à john ellis grand
physicien théoricien au cern
il a une médaille d'irak qu'il commente
mes dessins à ma grande surprise il les
a décrits comme si c'était des images
issues d'un microscope électronique
pas une seule fois il ne m'a parlé de
desseins il n'est pas du tout venu sur
mon terrain mais il était là en face de
moi
m'exprimant sa façon de voir le monde
les zones de confort s'entremêlent fort
bien et font les collaborations
fructueuses en étant pleinement lui même
il sort de son bureau
il s'ouvre à d'autres disciplines
d'autres perspectives et y apporte ce
qui fait sa singularité propres pourquoi
sortir esch de ma zone de confort elle
n'est pas fixe elle m'enveloppe je bouge
avec je vole avec essais depuis le
familier que l'on va pouvoir s'ouvrir
aux noms famille
que l'on va pouvoir apporter dans le
monde ce qui fait notre singularité
quand nous développerons notre courage
et notre souplesse
nous nous devrons de rester vigilant
quand la demande d'adaptation provient
de l'extérieur c'est très différent
il existe une violence qui normalise
l'insécurité et empêche l'établissement
d'une sérénité indispensable au travail
bien fait votre intuition saura vous
dire ce qui va dans le sens de la vie et
de l'ouverture et ce qui va au contraire
dans le sens de plus de contrôle et
d'exploitation
votre intuition sera vous dire ce qui
est inhumain et ce qui vaut au contraire
dans le sens de la vie ne cherchons pas
être originaux nous le sommes
soyons joyeusement nous-mêmes ne
cherchons pas devenir créatif nous le
sommes déjà allons à leur rencontre de
notre auto censeurs et faisons le rire
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]